someone making an appeal to authority
asserts that an argument like their own
argument or someone else's is good or
bad or that a claim is true or false
because an authority or someone they're
claiming as an authority says it's true
or false or good or bad the suppose
adora T could be a person a book an
organization or any other source of
information and this can be done in a
totally proper way much of the time
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
doing this plenty of sources are actual
qualified authorities on whatever topic
but where you run into trouble and your
appeal to Authority becomes fallacious
is when there's good reason to think
that your source is not necessarily
reliable as a source of information on
the topic at hand let's consider this
conversation Mike told me Beethoven was
heavily influenced by Mozart so what
what is Mike know he has a PhD in
musicology this would probably make Mike
a reliable authority on this topic what
if the conversation went like this Mike
told me Beethoven was heavily influenced
by Mozart so what what does Mike know he
looked it up online this would not
necessarily qualify Mike as an authority
on the topic an appeal to Authority
assumes this type of implicit premise
almost anything that X says about Y is
probably true if we don't have good
reason to think that this premise is
true then it's a bad appeal to Authority
a fallacy and the ensuing argument
cannot be sound almost anything that
someone says about Beethoven's
influences who has looked it up online
is probably true Mike looked up
Beethoven's influences online Mike told
me Beethoven was heavily influenced by
Mozart
therefore Beethoven was probably heavily
influenced by Mozart we are relying on a
false premise but let's replace the
first premise with almost anything that
a PhD
musicologist says about Beethoven's in
Florence's is probably true now we're
working with true premises but notice
that I'm saying in my premise anything
or almost anything that XS about Y is
probably true what an expert on a topic
believes about that topic is not
necessarily true but we can say that it
is probably true if it's established
that the expert is reliable experts
don't necessarily decide what's true
they merely report on findings in order
to tell you what is probably true and if
they discover contradicting evidence
they'll report something else but
determining whether a sources and
authority can be tricky different people
and different audiences have different
assumptions about who's reliable on
which topics let's say we're talking
about a scientific expert making a
scientific assertion best practice in
determining the reliability of a
scientists assertion about something
scientific is recognizing whether his
assertion agrees with the vast consensus
of the scientific community because when
we're appealing to the authority of
science we shouldn't be appealing to
what one scientist thinks it doesn't
matter what they think we're appealing
to what science as an enterprise or
institution has to say about the matter
that's how science works the consensus
is meant to be what we appeal to if 3
percent of scientists say a and 97
percent of scientists say B you can't
say science tells us a you can say that
science is wrong about B and give us
your own reasons for making that claim
or that science is unreliable in general
but that's a different matter altogether
therefore when appealing to science your
argument should sort of look like this
premise 1 the consensus of the
scientific community is Z premise 2 the
consensus of the scientific community is
the most reliable information available
conclusion according to the most
reliable information available Z is true
if you're rejecting the scientific
community's consensus your argument is
premise one the consensus of the
scientific community is Z premise two
the consensus of the scientific
community is not reliable conclusion
being we have no reason to think that Z
is true many people rejecting a
scientific consensus don't even realize
they're making this argument and often
don't realize that they have the burden
of proving premise two that the
scientific community is not reliable
they would have to prove that the
scientific community is unreliable on
many issues and proving that is an
uphill battle this miniseries has been
made possible in part by brilliant
you're watching this video so chances
are you have a genuine interest in logic
philosophy and problem-solving want to
further your mastery you should check
out this fascinating online learning
service with brilliant you can solve
hands-on puzzles and problems developed
by professors and expert professionals
from all over the world brush up on your
skills when it comes to logical
fallacies syllogisms deductive reasoning
game theory and other domains of
philosophy math and science quickly
become and all-around better thinker
sign up for free by going to brilliant
org slash critical thinking I've put a
link in the description under this video
and the first 200 people who visit
brilliant org slash critical thinking
will get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking